star platinum is generally a pretty
helpful existence for mr. Jotaro Kujo
although not without its flaws quite
specifically star platinum always had
this annoying habit of trying to get
George Morrow to hit the subscribe
button for the new Walter view which
look to be fair would grant him regular
juror content uploaded straight into his
YouTube feed and I would very much like
you the viewer to consider me as your
own personal star platinum now go ahead
and do the thing hello and welcome to
the new order video source for
everything anime manga and more
importantly welcome to the stand
encyclopedia where today we will be
making our first official entry into
this mammoth endeavor beginning with
what is undoubtedly one of the most well
known stands within the entirety of
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure being star
platinum star platinum is a close-range
natural humanoid stand that is very much
known as the ultimate punch ghost within
the series but that said there is an
awful lot more to start than that and
although this is a thought that I would
greatly contend with it is considered to
be the most powerful stand by various
characters within the saga as well as
the Creator hirohiko Araki himself but
we will get into that in any case the
stand is wielded by the mighty tior Cujo
and it was first introduced to us at the
dawn of part 3 stardust crusaders now
back in the early days of part 3 stands
took great inspiration from the world of
tower cards and star platinum in this
respect takes on the identity of the
star one of the major arcana which
represents big archetypal themes and
lessons and such and in the case of the
star this card can signify the feeling
of inspiration as well as renewed hope
and faith you know all of the inner feel
good stuff that humanity generally
strives towards in one form or another
achieving a sense of being blessed by
the universe at large which is why you
would probably never want to encounter
this card in Reverse because that would
signify the exact opposite including
feelings of despair and profound
disappointment in life and a lot of that
reflects star platinum very well as it
does serve as the primary hope of
Stardust Crusaders in particular and if
it does fail in any given situation then
that my friends would bring about a true
sense of despair in the giorgo universe
for both the characters as well as the
readers and watchers now in addition to
this star platinum may be one of if not
the only stand-in part three that might
contain a musical reference in its name
although I will stress that this is
unconfirmed but it may be possible that
it is a reference to a song called North
Star from the album platinum by
progressive rock musician Mike Oldfield
which was released in 1979 and it's
fun little jam actually simultaneously
super chill yet somehow full of energy
much like Churchill himself although
once again this could be a case of
simple coincidence here now as a natural
humanoid stance our Platinum has access
to a sliver of personality although this
persona very much reflects its user
Jotaro star platinum is often viewed as
a silent and stoic existence which could
lead you to mistaking it for a lifeless
presence however when it launches into
action its true self becomes immediately
clear releasing a violent aura that is
epitomized by the ever famous aura or a
battle cry despite this stop latinum is
very clearly its own entity capable of
acting without commands Ford wrote aura
which is seen in its introduction in the
series when Joe Tora fires a single
bullet into his head and star platinum
in the interest of self-preservation
stop said bullet although I guess there
was also an argument to be made that it
was acting under the subconscious desire
of Jorah who almost certainly did not
want to kill himself but in any case
let's move on to what this bad boy can
actually do because we have a fair bit
to cover for an initially simple seeming
stat as stated before star platinum is a
close ranged and meaning that at maximum
it can only be positioned about two
meters away from its user that is its
effective range which is unfortunately
restrictive but at the same time that is
about where the disadvantages for star
platinum come to a complete stop stop
platinum is obviously well known for
being a physically dominant existence
which is very very well reflected in the
statistics as it achieves a perfect
score in the areas of power potential
and precision speed and durability which
is utter madness and in theory it is
mere steps away from complete perfection
however what is holding it back is range
as predicted however even in that area
star platinum scores a C which is a fine
passing grade I suppose and it gives you
a very clear idea of just how wildly
dangerous the stand can be under the
calm collected and strategic use of Joro
now in regards to its raw strength I
feel like one of the greatest examples
we have of this was during der tors
battle with Midler who used the High
Priestess stand and the gang were
trapped in a giant mouth thing with the
only exit being blocked by teeth which
were touted to have the hardness of
diamonds but you know hottest known
natural substance on earth no big deal
because star platinum blitz right
through them like they were sugar glass
which is a stunning endorsement to power
as for speed while as previously
mentioned star Ponton was capable of
stopping a bullet being fired into
Jerry's head at point-blank range but
that is far from the most insane feat of
speed that this once
can achieve as through a funky
informational section on the stand
during pot six stop latinum was said to
be able to not only equal but surpass
the speed of light however there are
many things to note about this firstly
being that this could be an evolution
that was only present in the part six
incarnation of star platinum because it
had notably changed by then but I do
also need to point out that this is
inconsistent with everything that we
have seen from a stand and far from the
speed of light as we would know it in
reality although I am happy to believe
that startanim maybe operates on the
speed of light as is consistently the
Giorgio's universe but even then it's
it's questionable as is any time an
author is bald enough to say that
something is as fast as the speed of
light let alone excels it basically
though what I don't want is for anybody
to think that this is in any way
reflective of reality it is a bold manga
storytelling statement but in the
context of Jojo what we can still say is
that the stand is fast AF but one of the
more impressive features of star
platinum is its extreme precision which
is granted to it by supreme control of
bodily movement as well as enhanced
eyesight and to illustrate the eyesight
point I will say that we have seen this
thing gaze up to four kilometres ahead
as well as being capable of following
cards shuffled by a professional gambler
/ swindler but with that in mind star
platinum is able to perform actions of
complex surgery such as when it was able
to remove to use parasite from the
skulls of both Calculon ankle narf
without any damage to either of them I
should say and even knowing all of this
we still have not gotten to one of the
crowning features of star platinum which
would only make itself known at the end
of part 3 when it awakened a teeny tiny
ability to stop time which is a
technique known as star platinum the
world and obviously this is a carbon
copy of do stand to the world from which
star platinum in the world takes its
name in the amount of time that George
RR can stop differs depending on his
position in the series but in his prime
he could stop time for five seconds
although due to neglect in training of
the ability this becomes significantly
reduced later to around half a second
although Jarrett Road does pump it up to
1 to 2 seconds and eventually all the
way back up to 5 although George Roy
certainly never reaches DEA's prime in
which he was able to stop time for 9
seconds which is simply terrifying but
this brings us to the use of stamp
platinum by George Rowe who as we've
alluded to following Stardust Crusaders
very much fell into neglect with his own
stand now obviously this was likely due
to not having to face off against and
users
every two seconds you really had no
reason to invoke it and thus anyone
would become a bit understandably rusty
you know and stopping time is a pretty
big deal and something that he certainly
should have continued to train at least
a couple of times a day in the event of
I don't know let's say a major Universal
restructuring threat but that is all
hindsight the fascinating thing about
stop whinin though is that this is one
of the very few stands that we have seen
used over an extended period of time
and as such it has evolved during said
time with Jorah very notably in pot six
its name has been changed completely to
star platinum the world but not only
that it stats also changed quite
radically as well so at this point it
does still have an a ranking and
strength speed and precision as well as
maintaining its Lois Gail C rank for
range now whether its potential dropped
all the way down to C and even worse its
durability absolutely plummeted to the
rank of E however part six is a weird
situation where star platinum stats are
given twice one with its original form
very early on and then one with the
world attached to it much later so it's
entirely possible that the durability in
this regard may refer to how long dirt
rose capable stopping time for which is
nowhere near his full potential or
maximum endurance of ability although it
is possible that over the course of
stone ocean star platinum itself
underwent a radical change and that
became reflected in its latest stats in
any case territory does still make
pretty fantastic use of this stand
although he could do with a bit of self
improvement some other miscellaneous
things to consider about stop latinum
the stand has also shown the capacity to
manipulate its body on some level
particularly in regards to the star
finger technique in which it can extend
its fingers up to two meters in keeping
with its range restrictions but still to
devastating effect which is great
because it gives us down just that
little bit of extra utility not that it
really needed it but hey it's there
furthermore it also comes with an array
of other absurd techniques such as
incredible superhuman breathing which
was demonstrated against Enya when
stopped partner managed to inhale the
entirety of the Justus stand us
resulting in the suffocation and
subsequent defeat of Enya and it really
would seem like star platinum has that
sort of pocket knife utility that spawns
from its physical dominance for just
about every situation imaginable
like we need to visit truly godlike
levels of power before star platinum
even comes close to being outclassed now
as for my personal opinion on star
platinum it's very hard not to like the
stand because it does serve as more or
less the flagship for the entire concept
I do however take away at narrative
issue with just how ridiculously
overpowered it is but that's nothing new
with me in Georgia something I dislike
about Jojo in general as it stands very
rarely come with a cost for power and
some people just have extraordinarily
profound strengths while others don't
for no good reason
and the ones that do come with that
strength generally don't have many
drawbacks as a cost for invoking it and
stop fighting them firmly falls into
that category and yes I get that it is a
great reflection of Jorah himself but I
would probably very much have liked to
see something slightly weakly used in a
more creative way they did very much
enjoy when it added on its time-stopping
feature but mainly because I love the
effect it produces in both the anime and
the manga but it was another one of
those hate as if this thing was not
powerful enough already sort of
situations probably the thing I like
most about stop laughing though is that
it is a stand that well and truly fits
what I guess are Keys original intention
of them was a sort of representation of
a person's inner self which I think gets
done to varying degrees of success
within the series I mean there are more
than a few stands I've seen that I don't
believe match their uses at all but then
again we also don't really get to know
an awful lot of the users in the kind of
depth that you would need to make that
assessment but we do spend an awful lot
of time with Jotaro and unfortunately he
is a very quiet individual however
through stop button and we do get a
glimpse of the man behind that immovable
expression which is kind of scared
because star platinum can be a supremely
violent entity which tells us that Jura
has emotions just like any other human
being would especially that of anger and
fury which I guess is why it must have
been quite difficult to control at first
but star platinum to be also very much
serves as a personification of the
Joestar bloodline in general because it
was selected to be the entity that would
be needed to go up against the ultimate
form of deer and bring this over a
century old feud to a conclusion or at
least what we thought was a conclusion
so when I think about it like that yes I
do come to completely forgive how
absurdly powerful it is but despite that
I certainly wouldn't call it one of my
favorite stands in the series as I tend
to prefer the ones with more quirky
powers but in essence this is star
platinum arguably one of the most
powerful stands ever featured in JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure but once again I will
emphasize arguably however those are the
words of our key himself who has stated
that it is impossible to beat stop on
him and that was while steel boar Brom
was being published so yeah he may very
well be judging the concept of power in
a very different way to what I am but
there is no denying that star Putnam is
stand of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and as
such I am honored to add it as the very
first entry into the stand encyclopedia
but what do you guys think of star
Potanin please do let me know down in
the comments below we'll even join my
discord server and if you came for some
on charter content then please do go and
check out some of my other videos we'll
even subscribe to the channel a regular
Georgia Wanda delivered straight until
YouTube feed but for now this has been
the new old view and I'll see you next
time